Coursera was co-founded by Andrew Brower
his two brothers and it cost me to visit
Cornell Gregor Kerrigan in 2006 and
started and still is really this online
library a collection of class notes
essays exams for students uploaded by
students
before course hero I spent hours looking
for help online when I was stuck on
homework or studying for tests ever
since a friend told me about course hero
it's the only tool I use for every
course I just drop in whatever I'm
working on we started course for about
17 years ago in 2006 and the whole idea
was born out of helping students study
and helping students who are studying
for a test prepping and working on an
assignment and feeling stressed feeling
anxious and it was something that I had
empathy for being a student myself I
experienced it and so really when we
built it the idea was how can we best
build something that would help students
study and the lucky and most important
thing that we got right was that we
started we just did it and we kept
building in the beginning of
course hero we focused on crowdsourcing
uh resources study materials test prep
materials
materials helping people with homework
from students and Educators across
different campuses and the idea was can
we connect people to knowledge that came
from other people versus having to go to
people to get to the knowledge and the
the visual in our heads was to build a
wikipedia-like product that instead of
organized around in an encyclopedic
taxonomy we would build a product that
was organized around a course specific
school specific taxonomy course hero is
a Forbes 30 under 30 company and you
know with all of those companies we like
to stay in touch and we were seeing the
Acquisitions of course Sierra was making
in recent years and then how they
created their new parent company learnio
in late 2022 and so really jumped on
that news and became even more
interested in his strategy his
Acquisitions and just how they're
pivoting course hero began acquiry
companies in 2020 with his first
acquisition of Simba lab and since it
has Acquired and sounded businesses and
it really was a combination of things
that led them to this strategy of
acquisition you know first step-based
the increase competition in the Ed Tech
space
another Factor was a surge in Venture
Capital during the pandemic first hero
raised nearly 500 million total by the
end of 2021 and so that capital is
really used for their acquisitions
for another Factor where college
enrollment decreasing it led the company
to look for ways to diversify and so
that was through Acquisitions of
companies like Paul Bond and symbolab
focused on professionals and so the
company now rebranded under lerneo is
focused on adhering to both students and
professionals you know how do you take
that core clientele and carry it on
through the work world
building learnio and acquiring different
businesses that are founder-led with
really entrepreneurial Builder teams is
incredibly important at learnio the idea
idea of building a platform of
businesses and Founders each continuing
to be led by their CEOs is a belief that
decentralization and delegation of
autonomy is incredibly powerful and each
of us each of the CEOs are able to focus
on building for a closely clustered set
of customer needs they can go incredibly
deep and they don't have to worry about
another teammate or potential future
teammate being able to take on an
incredible new opportunity and that's
the opportunity to be able to balance
going super deep and also broadening and
going after New Opportunities it takes
an incredible amount of time and energy
passion to be able to start something
work on it build it over time time get
product Market fit get to expansion
phase and for us
that is something we want to really
facilitate and continue
post acquisition for us creating an
environment that empowers
autonomy and responsibility
entrepreneurialism just like when we're
startups individually
is incredibly powerful and that's core
to how we want to build learn you as a
platform of businesses that are powered
by founders
Builders and entrepreneurial Talent
Rohan Gupta is a co-founder of globot
which is essentially an ai-powered
writing and paraphrasing tool for both
students and professionals it was
founded in 2017 and acquired by lordio
in late 2021. my co-founder and I were
studying at the University of Illinois
Urbana-Champaign we both were in love
with artificial intelligence and we were
just tinkering with the technology
made a breakthrough in technology to
rewrite sentences I thought it was
pretty interesting just put it up on
Reddit and it started going viral and
that's how we found the cobot back when
we started in 2017 there was not a lot
of support for building AI tools
especially compared to what it's like to
build on top of AI today and yeah back
then we were just the three of us were
tinkering in an apartment on campus we
had next to no funding we just had a
small Grant from the University so we
had to be very Scrappy and it was just a
green field and every day was a new
experiment
I met Andrew in the winter of 2020 it
was really exciting I was a user for
course hero for several years and so it
was nice just meeting him as a fan and
then as a fellow entrepreneur
understanding his experiences and
getting advice from him it completely
changed her trajectory I mean one thing
is just having access to so many
brilliant Founders and CEOs to share
best practices with and learnings from
it's also been a privilege to be able to
partner with some of the best writing
businesses in the sector and collaborate
with them on new product development
uh and finally we just had access to way
more resources than we would have
otherwise
every single business has a unique
culture and a unique way of operating
and it's you can think of it as many
different experiments being run at the
same time
so seeing what works for another
business and how I can apply it to my
own has been invaluable especially
because everyone within learning it was
so transparent about what's working well
and what's not
some of the challenges in the evolution
of building up lerno from one business
to a platform of now eight companies
have to do with how can we make sure
that we stay true to our operating
principles of empowerment and
responsibility we think there's a huge
value in being a decentralized platform
and creating autonomy for the different
businesses and as you scale from not
just running one business with multiple
product lines to two to four to eight
being able to create an operating model
that is effective at each of those
stages is an incredible Challenge and
also something really fun to solve the
pandemic Style an increase of venture
capital specifically in that Tech space
and so now companies are kind of dealing
with the decrease in that from
2021 to 2022 it nearly half to but from
20.8 billion to 10.6 billion and so
companies are dealing with less Venture
Capital out there right now college
enrollment has decreased the last three
years as students in gen Z particularly
are rethinking the value of a college
degree and that means you know declined
customers for edtech companies like
learnio and so companies like Vernier
are asking themselves how do you
diversify in this space and so they're
focused more on professionals as well as
students and so lernios Acquisitions of
hobot symbol lab you know indicate that
trend of professionals using edtech
tools like these with artificial
intelligence tools like open AIS chat
and Google's Bard popping up it's really
created just a lot of competition for
these education technology companies
like horse hero and Czech I think with
so many students and professionals
looking for resources for maybe school
reports or business reports they're
looking for more of a free option that
if you touch EBT can provide rather than
a subscription service like Chegg or
coursero
check was kind of an extreme example
there where they had said chapter
affected sign ups it ended up vomiting
stock and
really just with these tools it's
creating a lot of competition for you
know customers both professionals and
students looking for tools like this
artificial intelligence is an incredible
theme and opportunity and disruption in
the world today and at lernia we're
incredibly excited about how these
Technologies and Transformer based
Technologies large language models are
impacting language summarization
translation question generation question
answering and I'm not sure I've ever
seen a time in our history of building
where there's so much opportunity and a
huge amount of energy being developed to
act fast and with conviction and to
iterate on a huge technological change
foreign
[Music]